I I don't know why you chose Fey Fey
self pronouns or to use the word
paganists when pagans would work just
fine say pronouns are self-identified
fairies that means that most of us have
been misgendering the Tooth Fairy all
this time hello hi I think we had kind
of this sexist assumption that the Tooth
Fairy is a female I've always referred
to her as a female but we should have
been saying Fey I guess by the way how
does that work so your pronoun
is now just your noun like it so you're
a fairy and that and then fairy is your
pronoun if you're an elephant then your
pronouns are I don't know Ella and Fant
how does that make any sense